why don't you just go help like cook
dinner with my mom she needs help you're
trying to be controlling but you're very
very disrespectful seriously about to
come over there
i am super shocked right now the kobe in
china would never talk to me like this
last week i was praising kobe for being
a gentleman from the looks of it kobe
has such a gentle heart which i won't
take that away from him he's definitely
shown some gentle qualities
but this week he picked a fight with
emily over pumping breast milk that had
me thinking pause
hold up
it was so unnecessary you see your fire
is right here i don't think that's
appropriate for you to be pumping in
front of your dad and it was in front of
her parents
i was
ready to jump into my head tube we're
gonna talk about it plus i was dreaming
that day i will be having breakfast in
bed
eve heads off to work and muhammad gets
upset that she doesn't make him
breakfast in bed he wants her to behave
like his mama and he is as serious as
serious can get
eve made me frustrated because
i expected her to cook for me because my
mom she usually cooks for me call his
mother
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
you know it's an interesting situation
i'm in doing these recaps because i'm
watching the show with you as a viewer
so from week to week depending on what
happens
my opinion changes or shifts when it
comes to the people we're talking about
and because i'm basically shouting my
opinion to the world
full transparency it can feel a little
awkward when i find myself praising
someone one week and then the next week
i'm looking at them sideways but
i guess that's life with new information
your opinion changes and also 90 day
cast members are humans and as humans
we're multi-dimensional look don't put
me in a box right
all right let's get into emily and kobe
by the way look at how adorable this
picture is kobe and cobin in matching
outfits earlier today kobe finally met
her son for the first time so it's been
a very long very emotional day for
everyone at the top of the episode it's
kobe's first day in the house with
emily's parents and after all the
excitement cobin finally lays down for a
nap so emily decides to pump her breast
milk in the living room while her mom is
cooking dinner and kobe thinks it's so
inappropriate hey
you just really have me
wet me pumping right here in the living
room this is not normal you can't be
doing this like in front of your parents
as well i've done it for my parents for
17 months the fact that your parents
touched you doesn't mean it's right keep
in mind that the entire time this
conversation is going on
emily's parents are listening
but that doesn't seem to face kobe why
can't you do that in
the basement
good i don't need to go to the basement
to come everyone in my family knows how
hard my breastfeeding journey was it was
super difficult for me so the fact that
i'm able to produce milk now when i
wasn't in the beginning is something i'm
really proud of and i'm not ashamed to
do it in front of my family i'm not
going to go downstairs in africa do
women go to the room to feed them
injured
oh that stopped emily's dad in his
tracks
you see your fire is right here i don't
think that's appropriate for you to be
pumping in front of your dad what do
y'all think about kobe's argument do you
think he has a point and remember this
isn't about breastfeeding or pumping in
public this is about doing it at home
around the people you live with
personally in regards to this situation
i think if emily is comfortable that's
all that matters
i know this is something that every
woman wouldn't be comfortable with but
if she is
what's the problem for most adults once
you see a boob and the initial shock of
oh that's a boob goes away it just
becomes what they are
breast
and if that's not the case for you
it's time to grow up also i'm not a
doctor
clearly
but i'm 99.9
sure that the primary biological
function of breast are to produce milk
to feed a baby not for sexual
satisfaction and speaking of sexual
satisfaction
i would hope that kobe is the only one
in that house sexualizing her boobs
so
i don't see what he has to be worried
about i think this is a matter of
accepting and respecting the fact that
they come from two different backgrounds
in africa women will be a little more
discreet according to kobe this is not
something they do in africa which my
africans out there i would love to hear
your take on that kobe also reveals in
this episode that his dad didn't come
into his life until he was 14. but when
it comes to emily she's had a totally
different experience
you see your face right here i don't
think that's appropriate for you to be
pumping in front of your dad
her father still views her as his little
girl she's she's my little girl
and they are close enough for her to
bring a random dude from africa into
their home and he offered to take care
of him for six months
so while emily breastfeeding and pumping
in front of her dad might be taboo for
kobe because of where he comes from and
how he views the father i wasn't brought
up like that
it's not taboo for her which in my
opinion that should be acknowledged and
once again respected
we're just standing there i don't want
to get in the middle of a
first uh discussion here
with my discussion about my boo kobe
apologizes to emily's dad for arguing in
front of him although he continues to do
it that's right i just uh you know oh my
god
we do things a little bit different here
i mean i don't see anything wrong with
this kobe then goes on to question why
emily is still breastfeeding the baby in
the first place when the baby's almost
two years old my younger sister she
stopped breastfeeding uh when the sun
was like seven months
now that's normal it's normal
you've been breastfeeding for 17 months
yeah
so how long i kept like babe he's not
coming even i told you this like listen
i'm coming home and you need to start
thinking on how you're gonna have to
like stop him from breastfeeding because
he wants that bond that cobin and i have
because it is such a bond
no emily we know that that is not the
real issue here
i don't know if she was trying to save
him or what
and how you're gonna have to like stop
him from breastfeeding because he wants
that bond that cobin and i have because
it is such a bond you know yeah listen
to kobe you know like yeah breastfeeding
is a big bond and i understand that but
it's like
i'm not going to take that away just
because you're here this time around it
shouldn't be like it's only about you
and him it's like us
emily's dad goes on to tell kobe the
longer the baby breastfeeds the better
he then tells the camera what this
argument really has him thinking i think
kobe was wrong completely i mean it was
uh it's perfectly natural for for emily
to want to do what she needs to do to
pump the milk and you know she's still
breastfeeding and it's pretty natural
here i was kind of surprised to hear
that it's not that common where he's
from
i was
ready to jump in if i had tube he was
kind of pretty strong-willed pretty
uh forceful
and it's disappointing
hmm disappointing
that's a good way to describe it when i
introduced kobe and emily a few weeks
ago teshumo said quote i'm just going to
say now that if kobe goes to america he
and emily's dad are going to butt heads
you might be onto something i'm sorry to
say this but we are talking about my son
okay our son awesome
yeah
seems to be doing pretty good
emily's dad is on standby for real seems
to be doing pretty good
finally kobe admits to the camera the
root of the problem he has with her
breastfeeding and pumping and it has
nothing to do with her parents being
around or the baby's age she's going to
be my wife and we make love you know
and
i have to suck her breasts
wait a minute kobe let's be clear you
want to you don't have to if anybody has
to it's the baby cause i love brace to
be honest all right
so
i can be sharing breasts in with my son
you know what i mean so i don't want to
sound being selfish over here but that's
just the truth
well kobe like father like son you love
them and so does your kid
can you really be mad
it's going to be interesting to see how
they work through this i'm sure a lot of
couples have dealt with a similar issue
i can be sharing breasts and with my son
you know i mean overall i think the
moral of the story for me at least is to
be mindful of how and where you express
your opinion to your partner you're
coming from different experiences
different backgrounds
and if you think something is unusual
it's okay to express that but how you
express it and when you express it
is key that's if you really want a
resolution let's not play games here i
can be fighting with you when people are
around we're having this first fight
about the breastfeeding and the pumping
it was kind of awkward that it you know
got brought up today and in front of my
parents like i don't like that why don't
you just go help like cook dinner with
my mom
listen to me i don't want you to sound
as if you know you're trying to be
controlling because i'm in america or
not it doesn't really happen so you're
trying to be very very disrespectful
seriously about to come over there and
just lose right on you
i just can't get over the fact that kobe
is saying all of this in front of her
parents and it's his first day there
let me explain something new
you can stand and talk to your future
husband like commanding me to go and do
something after emily asked him to go
cook dinner with her mom in a nicer way
are you inspiring
i said go help mom in the kitchen i
should have said
honey
yeah do you mind helping my mom in the
kitchen that's it you see the approach
now is totally different now kobe let's
not talk about approaches it would be my
pleasure to work with your mom in the
kitchen all right thank you
he goes on to help her mom cook and
emily reveals she's shocked by his
behavior the kobe in china would never
talk to me like this
we barely knew each other hmm
he was so sweet so laid back he was the
nicest guy and now kobe is like this
manly man trying to tell me what to do
i'm a little taken aback i was so mad at
emily she tried to stop the argument
fighting by giving me a command which
was very very rude and disrespectful
this is what she said why don't you just
go help like cook dinner with my mom i
guess it was rude and disrespectful to
him so kobe what are your expectations
of the united states i mean at kobe's
welcome home dinner he and emily's
father have a frank conversation about
his plans in the u.s
and what kobe says actually brings her
dad to tears maybe with time
i can see what i want to do yeah you got
to be willing to uh you know get to work
and
find a good job and provide for your
family
they're going to demand a lot of things
from you
you know i don't think kobe really has a
plan so i'm very concerned
she's she's my little girl
[Music]
so i'm really concerned about him being
able to provide
for her
for him and especially cobin later on
that night when it was time for bed oh
man feels good
i don't know if you're gonna have enough
room emily tells kobe she thinks it will
be best if he sleeps in the other
bedroom i don't know how he's gonna go
to bed with you in this bed
i think it's gonna be hard
and while she says it's because cobin is
distracted and the bed is too small i
think a part of her really just needed a
break
it's been a day say goodnight to cobin
[Music]
say
come here you know
i felt like left out and stuff like that
and i'm not coming to be sleeping alone
or sleeping away from my son you know
i've been away from him from very very
tender age like when he needed me and
i'm here right now and you're telling me
like i'm not going to be able to sleep
that's crazy
she has to give me this chance as a
father to play that role in our son's
life which he's not doing
ooh they have a journey in front of them
all right let's move on to this unique
situation between muhammad and eve my
name is mohammed i am 25 years old
i'm from alexandria in egypt
muhammad just moved to america to be
with eve who is a 48 year old
acupuncturist and massage therapist
eve also is a single mom and has a son
named theron who has special needs i
love my son there's challenges and it's
demanding sometimes so basically she
needs someone who is serious and who
will be a solid rock for her and her son
and from the looks of it
i'm not sure if muhammad is that guy he
keeps talking about how he wants his
wife to be like his mother my perfect
woman in my imagination is
that women will love me as my mother
and he means this in a literal sense
their first issue arises when eve
doesn't get a bidet installed for him
before he got to her house and if you
don't know what the day is it's the
thing that washes your behind
when you go to the bathroom so there's
one thing that i wanted to get done and
i didn't get done and it's the bidet
they will get it done
[Laughter]
all right
it's important to me
because
i practice islam and when you're going
to pray five times a day you're gonna be
facing god
so
you have to be clean 100
tissues for us it's not enough first let
me say i respect all religions i'm just
trying to digest muhammad's logic here
he's willing to break religious rules
and live with even her house before
they're married
and have sex with her before they're
married i hope that god will be okay
but he thinks god is more concerned
about his butt being extra clean
okay
i understand having a bidet of sorts is
a huge part of islamic customs but if
it's that big of a deal to muhammad i
don't know why she didn't gets this a
bidet
i think it would be wise for him to
handle it himself instead of putting the
pressure on someone like eve who doesn't
abide by those same rules
i can't believe you're in my bed
the second issue pops up during
muhammad's first morning in america eve
needs to head to work but muhammad feels
some type of way because he expected for
her to cook him breakfast
in bed i thought you're going to make me
breakfast this morning i'm sorry love i
got to go i thought i got to go
somebody's got to work
don't just get used to that
muhammad goes on to say that he's
frustrated with eve because she needs to
take care of his needs like his mom did
this is not what i was expecting for my
future wife
i'm already here one day
and i started to miss my mother well he
might need to go back home excuse my
grammar but ain't nobody gonna love him
like his mother wanting eve to fill his
mother's shoes is a lot of pressure to
put on her she already has to
financially take care of him and most
importantly she has the responsibility
of her son whatever happened to being
considerate i learned how to cook also
what has me a little concerned if to be
honest is that eve has the expectation
that muhammad is going to help watch and
take care of her son while she's at work
muhammad is very well aware that i've
been struggling to find consistent child
care and that
that is going to be his role to assist
me so i can work
i trust muhammad to be alone with my son
versus finding a babysitter
but the reality is it's not just going
to be an afternoon sometimes it might be
a whole day so i hope that he can handle
that but i don't know how that's gonna
work when muhammad wants someone to take
care of him i like taran and i don't
mind to help eve but i am feeling a
little bit more babysitter than a being
a beyonce hmm
all right well next week eve finally
gets muhammad's bidet installed but they
run into another issue
what's going on in here but he's gonna
install a
in islam is that's not right a man and a
woman cannot be a bone
am i allowed to be in the house if
there's a
no you would not love
okay 90 day fans fam that does it for
this week make sure you stick with et
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time
[Music]